here was an interesting moment on on cnn
anderson cooper was inter uh
interviewing this guy harry enton who
dives into a lot of numbers and polling
and all that kind of stuff and they well
just take a look obviously button's not
on the ballot but uh which party do
voters trust more right now uh uh you
know this is this is we might as well
call this segment the not surprise
segment uh the republican party they
much more trust the republican party by
20 points uh 51 i think to 31 you see it
on your screen right there on this is
just specifically on inflation this is
specifically on inflation this is
specifically on inflation if you look at
the broader economic spectrum as well
it's basically the same numbers but it's
inflation that is driving these numbers
and driving the numbers on the economy
and driving the negative perceptions
abiding and not surprisingly voters are
running the other way going a democrat
going to republicans i mean obviously
for democrats andy converse and jimmy
carter at this stage for president biden
that's it's not a good great comparison
there it it it's it's not a great
comparison and indeed what you're seeing
right now essentially is that if you
look towards what do voters think are
important towards the midterm elections
and and inflation has got to be what
number one number one numero uno what
you see right now look at this 48
percent say the most important issue in
their vote for congress is the economy
gun violence is not new work close
abortions not anywhere close immigration
which republicans were going to want to
run on not anywhere close and here is i
think the big takeaway when you look at
your generic congressional ballot so put
it all together right we're going to
make this giants do for you what do
voters feel right now look at this on
the generic congressional ballot we're
just looking at the best republican
positions dating all the way back since
1938 this is the best i repeat the best
republican position on the generic
congressional ballot basically of all
time okay so what's fascinating about
this is first off cnn does not want to
run a segment right like this right
anderson cooper you can see in his body
but he's sitting back he doesn't want to
hear this but they have to acknowledge
some level of reality they can [ __ ]
you and they can lie to their own
audience all the time but then at some
level you have to occasionally release
something true so people don't feel
completely gaslit and insane the entire
time but what they're in essence saying
is in these generic ballots people are
realizing the democrat policies putting
aside biden's cognitive stuff putting
aside the woke stuff and all of that the
fundamental policies the only thing that
these people are really supposed to do
it ain't working and that
is creating an incredible political
refuge for sane
people you